if you get accepted into these various
festivals do you plan to travel yeah I
take my resources very very seriously i
absolutely will not go to into debt and
so i will really look into the festival
i will i will look into films that were
there like in the last couple of years i
will contact those filmmakers and i
would say i promise you this is all you
know confidential was your experience
like I'm gonna do my research and find
out if it's worth it for me assuming
they don't pay for anything for me to
travel there so I what if I find that
it's worth worth the cost and expense
because it can be very well worth the
cost and expense you know you meet great
people and Thomas actually says
something really why's he says one of
your film festival strategies ought to
be a region in which you want to put
down roots so routes for sow seeds i
guess for your future films so let's
just say you have an idea that takes
place in the desert submit to arizona
festivals are nevada festivals because
now you're going to get to know these
people that's very wise so that's that
would be another reason so i did apply
to or submit to a few festivals that are
like in the indiana region because
that's where my wife's prom that's where
our next film is going to be and i
believe we have a good solid base there
so we'd like to connect with those
people and as you reach your room your
limit both in resources and time in
terms of how long you'll wait on the
festival circuit you know that have you
already mapped out your strategy beyond
beyond the film
what what comes natural for 19 different
girlfriend yeah again my goal or
girlfriend 19 was just to make it
honestly so I'm not sure here's the deal
with girlfriend 19 I'm very honest with
myself very honest with myself I could
maybe craft a really catchy teaser or
trailer and maybe get squeezed out a few
sales out of it just by the teaser alone
or trailer alone on whatever amazon
however you make my easy but the truth
is even in my trailer god bless her my
main actress and the other actors nobody
knows them you know I could expend my
time and energy on trying to squeeze out
a few pennies out of the film or I could
invest that time energy money resources
into my next film which if it ends up
being pretty good and all of a sudden I
have another movie it's the maker of you
know so that's kind of my strategy for
that I just I just don't like to invest
too much in something that I don't feel
is worth it and I'm not diminishing my
capacity you are nor my film just being
realistic here I'm taking that energy
that time those resources those
investments that could go into promoting
this thing that most people don't care
about taking that and then channeling in
that into the next thing and someone
might say yeah but that's not fair to
the actress and girlfriend I teen that's
not fair to those yes it is because if
this next thing becomes something people
are all going to want to watch the thing
that I did before that it's all
connected it's a web so that's my
mentality
you